molto probabilmente state pensando che
non si può raggiungere un punto più
basso basso di balli c'è un so se
ricordate valli
ecco la versione brutta del vostro prof
di matematica e per essere ancora più
brutta ce ne vuole
si è raggiunto un punto più basso in
realtà ed è balbina che sarebbe questa
credo sia una prof di matematica quelli
di fianco siete voi guarderete le
texture della libreria cristo esce fuori
dal dal muro no neanche quelche disegna
e un graffito di una libreria fantastico
che continua a giocare a sta roba
questa è la mia sedia canoa mai scusato
dentro il gioco mi fa piacere
chiaro riferimento a me possiamo
cominciare ragazzi start partiamo bene
in questa roba qui la partenza è
bellissimo ci super mario 64 c'è una
grafica migliore ragazzi cosa sotto la
cosa della corsa va bene in baldi ho
fatto cagare quindi qua si spera di fare
un po meglio questa attività da youtube
mi sorprende ogni giorno di più permesso
sono tavoli a caso regole o salve non ho
capito una sega di quello che ha detto e
ne sono veramente contento regole della
scuola mamma mia quanto sfocato lo
schermo regole della scuola in una
definizione che può non si legge sono
devono babe aveste ci sono degli
youtubers immagino conosco solo questo
in basso a sinistra anche se pixellato
lo riconosco e se tutor
questo è il pam cosa c'entra
vabbè fantastico l'alloggio dei trofei
per niente disegnato sul muro
andiamo avanti signora baldina per me ma
perché ci sono solo gli zaini ha esitato
non capisco quello che stai dicendo
proviamo a fare il test
essere o non essere preferisco non
essere cosa devo raccogliere devo
raccogliere gli oggetti come sempre
letteratura va bene però mi affanno la
fai farmi fare qualcosa
riusciamo sempre che stia qua prof e
suonata vado a far merenda
cosa è successo la lounge della
dell'insegnante va bene
gli insegnanti hanno lounge di buona
aereo permesso ma mi scusi chi è che mi
chiude sempre qua dentro
qual è lo scopo lista roba donna che
brutta rosa cioè io veramente ragadi
giochi brutti ne ho fatti sei anni ma
mio dio s'impegnano veramente basta
chiudermi qua posso uscire
fate uscire per cortesia questa roba
trovato un po di carta ho trovato una
pergamena devo prenderne otto in totale
va bene chi è sto pelato bruttissimo che
mi blocca la strada qualcuno mi spiega
ottima la risoluzione dei cessi ragazzi
io sono estasiato da sta roba comunque
all oggetto del giornale immagino serve
a distrarre qualcuno meglio l'ho
lasciato lì per terra chissenefrega devo
trovare altre pergamene con lì mi butta
nella lounge mia eccola baldina devo
scappare
devo scappare non mi tocchi brutto sto
tizio vorrei dire no no no no no bosco
demonio questo neanche ti tocca ti butta
nella lounge ti vede ti butta nella
lounge
no no scuoteva ogni ovale detto morto
vabbè è stato carino io non ho mai
giocato uno schifo del genere mi
veramente di dovete impegnare riproviamo
la cosa simpatica è che finalmente
aumentato la qualità della mia webcam
perché non è pieno verga mai una
videocamera [ __ ] ed è diminuita la
qualità dei soci cioè se ci si vedono da
schifo però la videocamera è [ __ ]
ma non ho capito ma la campanella devo
aspettare che suoni la campanella o
posso già andare in giro che mi faccio
andare in giro in teoria ma secondo me
la cavo non devo aspettare che sono e
vediamo se hanno messo l'italia c'è c'è
l'italia al contrario però vabbè non fa
niente
close inaf ha preso la barba nera una
quindi prima che suoni la campanella è
comunque un po di tempo per
salve di quale problema soffre lei
esattamente mi ha bloccato nella senza
presente secondi va bene no madonna
questo porca vacca gli manca pure il
naso che fastidio che non mi toccare due
le aiuti a fare un po di risolversi 26
meno 8 meno 2 a devo risolvere glieli
prima che arrivi baldina va bene sempre
più in basso in sti giochi o ecco
l'altra prima meta è una chiave anche
perfetto non so cosa siamo immensa va
bene due pergamene il suo comunque noto
che non so se lo ricordate maeland
airmen è uscito nel 2012
sei anni quasi sette sono cambiate un
sacco di roba tipo diminuita la qualità
video ludica fantastico gli avanti spero
di incontrarmi baldin africa ecco
infatti forse è meglio così guarda
perché poteva essere fuori dalla mia
porta
la madonna che fastidio meno 15 1 levati
stalli baldina porca vacca cori schivata
quello il bidello
ok non facciamo non ho visto niente io
no se si apre questa fase perché sicura
di prima non è comparsa nessuno perché a
me non voglio capire cosa presta chiave
quali abbastanza dello staff a l'assenza
dello staff era un tratto piede di porco
porca vacca
qualcuno ha mai finito un gioco di
ballino chiedo per curiosità perché
secondo me non è mai no che sì ma o iron
madonna t'ammazzo non ho capito quello
che ha detto ok a una più addirittura 4
su 8 rega posso sognare
finalmente un videogioco dove posso
vincere forse 5
mamma mia che pro gamer oggi visto che
sceglie i giochi a professionisti sono
bravo dio mio posso usare il libro al
libro serve per togliermi di mezzo
kakà via via via via via della croce o
trovare altre tre forza ce la posso fare
ai messa non c'è niente ho già visto
recuperare un pochettino di energia
spero non mi spunti davanti ballina in
questo istante sono non so cosa non s'ha
proprio da fare ecco la via via via via
vieni via no c'è il corridoio bagnato ma
questa non è acqua
ma porca vacca questo del detersivo
salve se in un gioco avessi capito che
quella era acqua non ci sarei andato ma
non non si capiva la gara gen
non era acqua quella difficilissimo però
ci voglia di provare la gara che
finalmente un gioco dove vado più vero
bene più o meno
allora io di nuovo di fare una roba
decente togliti madonna guarda che
fastidio chi puoi togliere grazie è un
abbiamo trovata togliti ma so che cosa
va mi spinge non lo voglio scoprire
fatto veramente bene comunque
oggi no no ok ha quindi un corridoio
randomicamente e ricoperto d'acqua così
da van deciso di fare così
vabbè mi piace veramente una resistenza
penosa ma quanto brutta comunque ho
calcolato che se cammina normalmente
all'inizio toriano dovrebbe fare
differenza poi dopo diventa difficile vi
dovreste spiegare questa necessità di
pulire per terra così tanto in squadra
c'è non è che ci caliamo per terra siamo
a tre
arco demonio porco ma non è vero dai
bambini dove poi stesso tipo nata ai ti
prego non mi vien donna da non adesso
forse forse riesco a scappare ancora
forse che culo via
che bello fare un dribbling di quelli
veramente importanti era però non lo so
se riesco ti devi toglie woodward a ti
ammazzo te lo giuro borri e veramente
orribile non è che ce l'ho con lui ma
minchia pulisce dove sono io che tra
l'altro è bagnatissimo ancora il
pavimento ma va bene presa no perché
ogni volta che prendo la pergamena
no mi sono scappato male
no non è vero dai dai fai serio
dice diceva ogni volta che prende una
pergamena lei va più veloce quindi devo
stare attento per questo che casino non
ci credo non ci credo mai non ci credo
non è possibile che culo
tu non puoi passare mi ha detto ma
almeno recuperato un po di energia tac
ciò panino mi sa che devo dare al
bidello e tonino questa era la
c'è un libro che dietro nuovo visto
prima effettuare camera siamo a 7 no
ragano no no no no no mi rifiuto glorie
ma va a cagare
dai dai raga minchia 7 su 8 ce la farò
mai più veramente impossibile da cipro
ancora una volta l'intero vicinissimo
secondo me devo guardare bene dove sono
tutte e poi andare a cercarle dopo la
vede scattare subito a una una va bene
per due ok se matre in gen tre secondi
non presenterà come possibile no no no
giornale giornale anno mi ha toccato a
bene non ho mai capito che la regione
babe chissenefrega non mi toccare non mi
ha toccato come così ecco infatti
sembrava stranissimo assente qua sono
entrata dall'altra no ma essi non mi
chiara che non si decide sto male ok
perfetto via via vere non ho sbagliato a
porta non è vero guadagna impossibile
genova è veramente c'è inguardabile sta
situazione ma quanta sfiga il tipo si
deve trasporta in una davanti alla porta
a caso è di chi blocca minchia sempre la
mia o vabbè raga è stato orribile mai
più una roba del genere cioè vi giuro un
gioco c'è ignobile cribbio però magra io
ho giocati più votanti e ma questo
miglia veramente sopra ogni roba ragazzi
spero che mi sia piaciuto che sarà
ballina come al solito se vi è piaciuta
al momento è un mi piace anche a vari
social capito cosa descrizione se non si
discute non ci vediamo l'anno prossimo
video da ragazzi
[Musica]